Phoenix forgotten is the latest found
footage movie that tells the story of
three teenagers in the Arizona desert in
1997 that went missing
these events are recounted by a
present-day documentary that a relative
of one of those missing teenagers is
making and the present-day combines with
the past as they watched the collection
of tapes that one of those teenagers
shot in 1997 we see that footage and we
uncover a mystery of how these kids
disappeared now the story of this movie
revolves around the phenomena of the
Phoenix lights it was a story that was
really big in 97 some lights appeared
over Phoenix Arizona
hundreds of people saw them and it was
very well documented the governor said
it was a hoax but later after he was out
of office said that it wasn't a hoax and
he has absolutely no idea what it was so
that only catapulted the controversy
even more and there have been so many
films about this and it was definitely
something that fascinated me and sitting
down in this theater I didn't really
know what to think because it's another
found footage movie and right there I'm
kind of rolling my eyes before I even
see it which isn't really a good thing I
try not to go into movies with
preconceived notions but it's tough I
mean we all have seen and heard what
found-footage movies can do for the most
part it's a very long barrage of jump
scares and extremely shaky and cheap
filmmaking to hopefully make a quick
profit by this point we know that the
Blair Witch Project was huge and that
was like a big shock to the system for
people and Cannibal Holocaust even
before that but nowadays we kind of we
understand the routine with these movies
we know how they're made and we know
it's easy to make money but the thing
that surprised me about the marketing
for this was that it was actually
executive produced by Ridley Scott and
his production company Scott free and so
I went into the movie thinking this
could be better than most and it is I
found this movie surprisingly effective
this film captures what's really
important about the whole UFO paranoia
conspiracy stuff that shows like the
x-files made extremely popular and that
is the obsession that comes with it if
you are a person who feels like they've
had some sort of experience whenever
I've read into these experiences because
conspiracy kind of fascinates me
and sometimes I like
to do research on my own like for
instance my mom and I back in the day we
actually went to a library and look
through those old microfilm readers and
looked at old newspapers dating back all
the way to 1947 when the whole Roswell
thing happened all the way up to the
Phoenix lights in Arizona so I've
always had a bit of a fascination with
this so full disclosure I am a little
biased this is the subject that already
interests me going in of course this is
completely fictional but what I really
did appreciate about this movie is that
I honestly couldn't count even one
jump-scare this is a film that is
essentially a mystery the first two acts
of this movie set up a fairly compelling
mystery you see the past footage from 97
of what happened to these kids before
they eventually disappeared and then we
cut back to present-day and his sister
is combing through this footage and
trying to interview people involved with
it so it's less of a jump scare fest and
more of a compelling family mystery
where you have characters that are
simply trying to figure out what
happened to their loved ones and that's
something that I think this film
captured really well beyond just having
some kids in the mountains seeing some
scary they actually focused more on
the family and their trauma we're
dealing with whatever happened to their
kids because no one knows where they are
and that gave the film some emotional
weight modern-day UFO and alien movies a
lot of them suck and they don't really
understand what makes the genre work
it's not just about like a creepy forest
or a strange desert or lights in the sky
it's kind of the same thing that made
the movies zodiac work so well for me
beyond all of the things that are so
perfect about that movie I love zodiac
the thing that made the film really
stand out was Jake Gyllenhaal's
character and his obsession that he
develops with the Zodiac killer and the
fact that pretty much all other things
become less important to him in this
movie the guy who's filming the
documentary in the 90s you can tell that
he has that similar obsession that he's
developing because in the third act of
the movie when you're watching the final
tape and you're starting to uncover
things there were all these moments
where you're like dude you need to get
out of there now but he wants to stay he
just wants five more minutes he just
wants a few more minutes to hopefully
get that shot that will make him feel
right and even though it's not explored
that much in the script
I could be attributing a lot of this
myself it was actually captured fairly
well in the movie that sense of paranoia
that a lot of people felt at that time a
lot of movies that are about aliens or
UFO abductions kind of missed that and
they think they just have to show creepy
stuff in the sky and maybe an alien
walks by a window or something and
there's a weird
ear piercing sound effect the best types
of UFO films or TV shows are always
about the paranoia and the obsession
that comes with it and this film
understands that really well it also
competently recreated 97 fairly well and
the feel of that era with the technology
that's used
there's even a school rules and
regulations video that you see one of
the characters doing that feels exactly
like any of those like Morning Report
videos you may have watched in school at
the time there is one glaring error that
I noticed though a character directly
references the movie contact which did
come out in 97 but in july and the
footage in this movie is in march so
they would never have seen it at that
point so that was like okay i was really
obvious and one of the characters that
disappeared is shown to have owned the
x-files movie on VHS tape which wasn't
even released in theaters until June of
1998 let alone Home Media so he never
would have owned that tape that leads me
and some of my negatives I would say the
present-day footage with the sister
recounting the past I wasn't too
invested in that and that's kind of
important you're supposed to be and I
just kept wanting him to go back to the
past footage so I could learn and
uncover that mystery also in the found
footage segments of the movie I would
say that I heard wait what is that
maybe like 15 times that exact line of
dialogue wait what is that what is that
what is that a light is that a UFO is
that a trailer is that a streetlight
wait what is that over and over and it
just kind of got old after a while
surprisingly so Phoenix forgotten is a
pretty effective found footage movie
it's not excellent it's not going to
blow anyone's minds but I am
disappointed that really no one is
talking about this and it's kind of just
being thrown into theaters again not an
amazing film don't go to this expecting
like the next Blair Witch Project but it
is a surprisingly investing found
footage movie and fortunately I was the
only person in that the
so I feel like a lot of people are
probably going to miss this movie for
other films this weekend but if you have
an interest in this sort of thing maybe
give it a chance I'm going to give
Phoenix forgotten of be guys thank you
so much as always for watching I greatly
appreciate it tonight I'm going to go
see unforgettable and man I hope it's
unforgettable in the way I'm expecting
it to be guys you are the best thank you
very much for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
steppen eyes
[Music]